what to you
is existentialism
so it's a hard question i'm teaching a
course on existentialism right now you
are i am yeah existentialism in
literature and film which is fun
uh i mean the traditional thing to say
about
what existentialism is is that it's a
movement in mid 20th century
mostly french some german philosophy
and some of the major figures associated
with it are people like jean-paul sartre
and camus
sivan devoir
maybe martin heidegger
but that's a weird thing to say about it
because most of those people denied that
they were existentialists and um
and in fact i i think of it as a
movement that has a much longer history
so when i try to describe what the core
idea of existentialism is it's an idea
that you find expressed in different
ways in a bunch of these people one of
the ways that it's expressed
is that
sartre will say
that existentialism is the view that
there is no god
and at least his form of existentialism
he calls it atheistic existentialism
there is no god
and
since there's no god there must be some
other being around
who does something like what god does
otherwise there wouldn't be any
possibility for significance in life
and that being is us
and the feature of us according to sart
and
the other existentialists
that puts us in the position to be able
to play that role is that we're the
beings for whom
assart says it existence precedes
essence
that's that's the catch phrase for
existentialism and then you have to try
to figure out what it means
what is existence what is presence and
what does it proceeds mean yeah exactly
what is existence what is essence and
what is proceeds and in fact precedes a
starts way of talking about it and other
people will talk about it differently
but here's a way of here's the way start
thinks about it this is not i think the
most interesting way to think about it
but get you started
sartre says
there's nothing
true about what it is to be you
until you start
existing and still use until you start
living and for sartre the core feature
of what it is to be existing the way we
do
is to be making decisions to be making
choices in your life to be
sort of taking a stand on what it is to
be you by deciding to do this or that
and the key feature of how to do that
right for art
is to do it in the full recognition of
the fact that when you make that choice
nobody is responsible for it other than
you
so you don't make the choice because god
tells you to you don't make the choice
because some utilitarian calculus about
what what it's right to do tells you to
do you don't make the choice because
some other philosophical theory tells
you to do it there's literally nothing
on the basis of which you make the
choice other than the fact that in that
moment
you're you're the one making it you are
a conscious
thinking being that made a decision so
all the questions about physics and free
will
are out the window
yeah that's right if you were a
determinist about the mind if you were a
physicalist about the mind if you
thought there was nothing to your
choices
other than the activity of the brain
that's governed by physical laws then
there's some sense in which it would
seem at any rate like um you're not the
ground of that choice the ground of that
choice was the physical universe and the
laws that govern it and then you'd have
no responsibility and so sart's view is
that the thing that's special about us
used to be special about god
is that we're responsible for
becoming the being that makes the
choices that we do
and sart thinks that that simultaneously
empowering i mean it practically puts us
in the place of god
and also terrifying
because what responsibility how can you
possibly take on that responsibility and
he thinks it's worse than that he thinks
that
it's always happening
everything that you do
is the result of some choice that you've
made the posture that you sit in
the way you hold someone's gaze when
you're having a conversation with them
or not
the choice to make a note
when someone says something
or not make a note
everything that you do presents you as a
being who makes decisions and you're
responsible for all of them so it's
constantly happening and furthermore
there's no fact about you
independent of the choices and actions
you've performed so you don't get to say
it's hart's example i really am a great
writer i just haven't written my great
book yet
if you haven't written your great book
you're not a great writer
and so it's it's terrifying it puts a
huge burden on us
and um and that's why sart says
on his view of existentialism
human beings are the beings that are
condemned to be free
our freedom consists in our ability and
our responsibility to to make these
choices and to become someone through
making them
and we can't get we can't get away from
that but to him it's terrifying not
liberating
in the positive meaning of the word
liberating well so he he thinks it
should be liberating but he thinks that
it takes a very courageous individual to
be liberated by it
um nietzsche i think thought something
similar i think's art is
really coming out of a nietzschean sort
of tradition
but what's liberating about it if it is
is also terrifying
because
it means in a certain way you're the
ground of your own being you become
what you do through through existing so
that's one form of existentialism that's
a stark atheistic version of it there's
lots of other versions but it's somehow
um organized around the idea that it's
through living your life that you become
who you are it's not facts that are
sort of true about you independent of
your living your life
you